[Música]
y
cientos de personas hicieron vigilia de
noval de texas por los 19 niños y 2
maestras asesinadas en la escuela
primaria rock las autoridades
confirmaron que el autor de la masacre
publicó sus intenciones en redes
sociales antes de atacar el hecho reabre
el debate sobre el control de armas
más de 40 localidades fueron atacadas en
el donbass ucraniano golpeando al menos
47 objetivos civiles el gobernador del
lugar dijo que ya cayó el 90 por ciento
de su región al tiempo que un alto cargo
militar ucraniano reconoció que rusia
tiene la ventaja en los combates tenemos
reportes
18 millones de venezolanos viven en
colombia una cifra que aumentó en los
últimos años y muchos de los migrantes
se han enfrentado a expresiones
xenófobas que aumentan en el contexto
previo a las elecciones presidenciales
colombianas del 29 de mayo en france 24
continuamos con la serie de reportajes
especiales de cara a la cita electoral
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en eeuu allí la
comunidad de walden texas realizó una
vigilia por los 19 niños y dos
profesoras asesinadas en la escuela
primaria rock al tiempo numerosos
colegios a lo largo y ancho del país
realizaron homenajes a las víctimas del
tiroteo un hecho que ha reabierto el
debate sobre la regulación del acceso a
las armas en el país desde el lugar de
la tragedia nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vásquez no se
amplia
estamos acá justo al frente de la
escuela elementary a rob donde fue el
miércoles este tiroteo que dejó 19 niños
muertos dos profesores también muertos
hemos hablado con la comunidad lo que
nos dicen es que el tema de las armas es
un tema que ya dan por sentado que no se
puede según ellos seguir argumentando
que se vaya a hacer algo al respecto y
que entonces a partir de ese es dado ese
supuesto de que va a ser muy difícil
cambiar la legislación con el tema de
las armas lo que pide la comunidad
entonces es más seguridad más seguridad
a la entrada de los colegios más
seguridad a la hora de poner cercas
afuera más educación a los a los
maestros a los policías que guardan este
colegio y otros colegios aquí en ubaldo
igual de una población de 16 mil
habitantes mayoría de ellos son latinos
son hispanos es una comunidad muy
religiosa muchas muchas iglesias
alrededor de esta ciudad ayer
precisamente en la vigilia varios
pastores estuvieron ahí hablando
compartiendo su mensaje religioso a la
comunidad y entonces hemos venido
también hablando y acá pueden ver detrás
mío con la comunidad que se ha acercado
hoy a dejar flores a dejar obsequios a
dejar su memoria sus sentimientos su
sentir su sentido pésame sobre esta
tragedia que vive este pueblo se acercan
acá los policías también han traído
flores ha traído flores la comunidad
brevemente también se han dado ruedas de
prensa para estar actualizando el estado
de la investigación de este de este
crimen de este homicidio se deja a 19
niños muertos entretanto en washington
fracasó en el senado el intento de los
demócratas por responder a las recientes
tiroteos registrados en el país los
republicanos votaron en contra de que
saliera adelante el proyecto de ley
sobre terrorismo doméstico el líder de
la mayoría demócrata en el senado chuck
schumer dio dos semanas de tiempo para
nuevas negociaciones
entonces sé que las posibilidades de
obtener diez votos para este proyecto
son muy pequeñas desafortunadamente por
la influencia de la toma vista de los
republicanos muchos republicanos han
dejado clara su posición de nuevo hay
muchos trompistas para fines la
violencia armada
a terrorismo doméstico un tiroteo en una
escuela un tiroteo en un barrio o en
otro lugar nunca nunca los convencerá de
tomar alguna medida
y más noticias llegan desde eeuu el
gobernador de oklahoma afirmó este
miércoles la ley más restrictiva sobre
el aborto del país prohíbe la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
desde la fecundación y permite a los
ciudadanos denunciar a cualquier persona
que ayude a otra a abortar ampliamos en
el informe
la ley más restrictiva sobre el aborto
en eeuu entró en vigor la noche de este
miércoles el gobernador de oklahoma
kevin state firmó la nueva ley que
prohíbe el aborto en cualquier momento
de la gestación el embarazo sólo se
interrumpirá en caso de emergencia
médica o si el resultado de una
violación o de incesto denunciado ante
las autoridades el gobernador
republicano steve publicó un comunicado
que dice
prometí a los ciudadanos de oklahoma que
como gobernador firmaré cada propuesta
legislativa pro-vida que llega a mi mesa
y estoy orgulloso de cumplir esta
promesa hoy desde el momento que la vida
empieza con la concepción tenemos la
responsabilidad como seres humanos de
hacer todo lo que podamos para proteger
la vida del bebé y la de la madre esto
es en lo que creo y en lo que la mayoría
de ciudadanos de oklahoma creen
[Música]
la ley es parte de la política de los
republicanos de restringir el derecho al
aborto en los estados donde gobiernan y
llega tras la filtración de las
deliberaciones de los magistrados de la
corte suprema que pretenden revocar la
sentencia de roe versus wade que
legalizó el aborto a nivel federal
cincuenta años atrás y que continúa
dividiendo el país anualmente se
practican 600.000 abortos legales en
eeuu 5000 de estos en oklahoma
en noticias de la guerra en ucrania
rusia bombardeo más de 40 localidades en
la región oriental de donbass los
ataques cayeron sobre 47 ubicaciones
civiles dejando al menos cinco muertos y
más de una docena de heridos el
gobernador del gans dijo que más del 90
por ciento de la provincia estaba bajo
ocupación rusa al tiempo que un alto
cargo militar ucraniano reconoció que
rusia tiene la ventaja en los combates
en dicha región
las tropas del kremlin buscan rodear a
las fuerzas ucranianas en las ciudades
de severodonezk ilicic antes nuestra
enviada especial catalina gómez ángel
tiene más detalles la batalla se
intensifica en el donbass donde hoy las
tropas rusas habrían tenido el control
por unos momentos de una de esas retenes
que controlan esa ruta que va de la
ciudad de bach mut hasta las poblaciones
de liz y sants y se vieron ex en la
provincia de luján que están asediadas
por las fuerzas rusas desde hace varios
días según el gobernador de la provincia
esta ruta sigue estando en control de
los ucranianos después de esta batalla y
es la única manera de axe allí sin
embargo el gobernador decía que las
tropas ucranianas habrían salido de
controlar algunas áreas de esa provincia
y de esas ciudades sin embargo otras
versiones que vienen desde allí desde el
campo militar dicen que los ucranianos
están reforzando esas posiciones y
todavía están luchando por controlarlas
la única realidad que sabemos es que
cada vez los heridos son más la
situación es más crítica para quienes
pelean allí se habla de que 25
batallones rusos están tratando de tener
el control de esta zona mientras que
allí hay tres brigadas ucranianas lo que
representaría alrededor de 10.000
hombres todos los días llegan cada vez
más heridos a esa población de bach mudé
a las ciudades aledañas pero las también
las armas se intensifican en el número
de armamento y de logística que llega
hacia la región cómo hemos sido testigos
durante los últimos días es cada vez
mayor y las tropas ucranianas siguen
luchando a pesar de las dificultades y
de los avances de las tropas rusas
en el salvador el régimen de excepción
impuesto por el gobierno de nadie buque
le fue prorrogado por 30 días más en sus
primeros dos meses de vigencia cerca de
35.000 personas han sido capturadas por
supuestos vínculos con grupos de
pandillas tras esta medida se han
multiplicado las denuncias de
detenciones arbitrarias según han
informado organismos de derechos humanos
el informe es de nuestro corresponsal
vladimir tovar
marta morales de 70 años ha recorrido
las cárceles durante días buscando a
tres de sus familiares que fueron
detenidos en medio del estado de
excepción declarado por el gobierno
salvadoreño a finales del mes de marzo
mire yo lo que más quisiera desde que
estas cosas llegarán a nuestro señor
presidente porque él ha ordenado que se
capturen a los delincuentes no las
personas civiles y yo siento que van
parejos o sea no entiendo por qué
capturan a las personas que no tienen
nada que ver con cosas delictivas
si bien el gobierno asegura que las
capturas son de integrantes de pandillas
organizaciones de derechos humanos
reportan centenares de arrestos
arbitrarios los familiares de los
detenidos confirman que los arrestos son
sin orden judicial y sin investigación
las autoridades de seguridad han
reconocido la muerte de 11 personas bajo
custodia penitenciaria entre ellos el de
william galeas
la última vez que lo vi fue ese día por
la mañana
y casi un mes después lo veo pero no en
las condiciones que yo quería no es
parte del alma toda la familia
del otro lado de la ciudad víctor su
nigga no tiene tiempo para ir a
preguntar por su pareja arrestada a
inicios de mayo ya que tiene que
trabajar y cuidar a la hija de ambos de
apenas nueve meses
porque la gente la escucha y oral
pero no lloro de dolor sino que de
angustia por el olor a madre por el
sentimiento de la madre
el temor de víctor es no volver a ver a
su compañera el de los defensores de
derechos humanos es que la
transgresiones se vuelva una situación
permanente mientras el gobierno celebra
la efectividad de las medidas especiales
que fueron extendidas por otros 30 días
cada vez son más las personas que
abarrotan las afueras de las cárceles en
búsqueda de sus familiares detenidos
y el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador adelantó que este viernes
definirá su asistencia a la cumbre de
las américas el mandatario insistió en
que su asistencia organizada por eeuu
depende de que inviten a todos los
países esto luego de la polémica por la
intención del país anfitrión de no
invitar a cuba venezuela y nicaragua por
su parte el presidente de cuba miguel
díaz-canel aseguró que no asistir a
ningún caso aunque sea invitado y
denunció las presiones que ha habido
sobre países como méjico por pedir una
cumbre inclusiva
18 millones de venezolanos viven ahora
en colombia una cifra que aumentó
rápidamente con la llegada masiva de
migrantes en los últimos años esta
población se enfrenta a expresiones
xenófobas que suelen aumentar en
contextos políticos complejos como las
elecciones presidenciales manuel a cano
aitor txábarri y lionel para ser y nos
cuentan más
amor leyó
cuatro años han pasado desde que jean
carlos y su familia llegaron a colombia
desde venezuela pero ese tiempo no acabó
con la discriminación que los rodea
especialmente a sus hijos en el primer
grado que estuve estudiando unos niños
le clavaron una punta de la piel en la
pierna verdad y entonces
cuando fuimos a reclamar la profesora
dice que nosotros no tenemos derecho a
reclamar
porque porque somo venezolana cruzaron
una extensa frontera para toparse con
otro tipo de barreras unas que se
dirigen sobre la xenofobia que crecen
ante las elecciones presidenciales todas
votaciones en cualquier país afecta
directamente a toda la población que
estés y sobre todo más a la población
migrante nosotros ahorita estamos en una
zozobra porque no sabemos qué es lo que
va a ocurrir con nosotros
son estos momentos de tensión política
que le dan sentido al barómetro de
xenofobia alejandro un joven venezolano
es codirector de la plataforma que
monitorea los discursos alrededor de la
población migrante los comicios
presidenciales encienden sus alarmas
analizamos también todas las
declaraciones que han dado los distintos
candidatos a la presidencia y candidatas
la mayoría ha sido una gran ausencia
esto es preocupante porque finalmente
unas políticas más importantes que tuvo
el gobierno eduque una de las pocas que
se felicitó a nivel nacional
internacional ha sido la integración de
las personas migrantes venezolanas con
política migratoria primera que no hace
eco en la sociedad colombiana una
encuesta de invamer muestra que 60% de
la población no está de acuerdo con que
el gobierno acoja a los migrantes
venezolanos lo que hemos visto es que
cuando se incrementan los niveles de
xenofobia hay mayor posibilidad de
vulneración a los derechos a las
personas migrantes
en medio del panorama gris sobresalen
algunos destellos
como los platos de comida que entrega my
ir a una voluntaria venezolana en este
comedor comunitario a través de este
programa hemos logrado
y bajar la discriminación e incluso
tenemos un comedor
mayor parte para migrantes venezolanos
entonces ha sido una manera también de
integrarlo a la comunidad a la sociedad
donde en este momento están haciendo
vida pero estas iniciativas no son
suficientes en 2021 más de 60.000
hogares migrantes no tenían acceso a la
salud y más de 200.000 vivían en
hacinamiento crítico unos pendientes a
los que se enfrentará quien llegue al
palacio de nariño
el actor estadounidense ray liotta
conocido por su papel en la película
goodfellas entre otras falleció este
jueves a los 67 años en santo domingo la
capital de la república dominicana donde
se encontraba filmando una película su
publicista aseguró que elliot a falleció
mientras dormía pero habrá que esperar a
las informaciones oficiales de las
autoridades
hasta aquí este repaso a las noticias
internacionales sigan conectados a
france 24 y recuerden que pueden ampliar
toda esta y mucha más información en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]